[Música]
la tierra es con frecuencia un asunto de
familia los bulearon son productores de
cereales de Padre A Hijo desde 1912
ellos son Roger Erick y Matías tres
generaciones de agricultores dedicados
actualmente a cultivar un ceto de
manzanos para bordear sus campos para
ellos 3 cada día de labor es una
oportunidad de aprendizaje para
transmitir
he conocido agricultores el hijo tenía
45 años no hacía sus pedidos solo
desde mis 22 años me apoyó durante dos
años lo mismo que hice con Erick
transmitir lo que me dio mi padre para
darle esas responsabilidades y dejarlo
trabajar Bajo su iniciativa
a sus 49 años Erick tomó las riendas del
cultivo desde hace tiempo pero aún
cuenta con su padre
aún hay conocimientos no asimilados
entonces eso permite progresar
aprender del papá y del abuelo no
siempre es fácil para Matías de 18 años
pero eso hace parte del aprendizaje
Matías tomará las riendas del cultivo
dentro de tres años pero aún debe
aprender hoy ejercicio práctico en este
campo de tomillo según él es hora de
desmalezar
muchachos
está un poco grueso podemos intentar si
quieres pues
su padre desempeña el juego antes de
parar los estragos
[Música]
qué ocurre no sé si has entendido está
muy grueso lo está vinaste esta planta
sigue la Tierra
no está bien arreglada estás consumiendo
combustible pierdes el tiempo deberías
ir a jugar con tus amigos Un aprendizaje
exigente para Matías ya que la vida
cotidiana no siempre es fácil para los
agricultores
a la hora de la cena frente a los
álbumes familiares Roger el abuelo
recuerda su juventud en la granja mira
después de realizar tu examen final de
la secundaria trabajaremos así tienes
una idea de ello Este es mi abuelo
materno está golpeando el trigo gira el
heno golpea de nuevo mira cuando ya no
hay más trigo en las espigas las dejas a
un lado y luego Esto es lo que resulta
para mí es una bella imagen buen
recuerdo lo es
sin embargo su abuelo lo hizo todo para
desmotivarlo
mi nieto no hagas esta tontería no te
dediques a este oficio
sí me lo dijo luché trabajé mucho
pero estoy orgulloso de lo que he hecho
tú dentro de unos años la quinta
generación tomará el relevo
transmitir este amor por la tierra a sus
nietos también es lo que motiva a
christoph Piqué un agricultor instalado
en Mayén
[Música]
Sabes que por primera vez escuchamos
cantar a las aves esta mañana son siete
nietos su nacimiento provocó un cambio
El agricultor tradicional se volcó a lo
ecológico un respeto por la naturaleza
que trata de inculcar hoy el trabajo de
la pequeña tropa consiste en hacerle
mantenimiento a estos árboles fueron
sembrados hace dos años
levanta un poco más tu mango
El golpe es 10 veces más importante
el árbol es el futuro de la humanidad
esta hora hemos pensado más en nosotros
que en ellos
el clima cambia y cambia tan rápido que
es urgente muy urgente
una convicción que quiere transmitir
cuando sembramos árboles un día estos
absorben CO2 nos traen aire y el planeta
vivirá mejor la planeta hace unos años
como muchos otros christoff había
cortado los setos para pasar su tractor
por los campos pero con la ayuda de
civil agricultor forestal entendió que
el árbol en realidad es una ventaja para
las praderas es un pequeño roble no muy
fuerte pero crecerá de nuevo va bien y
eso es bueno
Tiene dos siglos por existir si no es
más el árbol es un cuchillo suizo es la
biodiversidad las aves los insectos todo
sin luego cuando Kristoff retoma la
granja de sus padres hace 40 años no se
hace preguntas productos químicos en sus
campos y antibióticos para sus vacas
pero el malestar llega entonces hace 12
años se vuelca lo ecológico
ya no podía soportar esos Barros de
tratamientos con calaveras encima Para
mí era imposible sabía que actuaba mal
siempre estuve dividido en dos
entre las ganas de hacer crecer la
facturación por todos los medios
posibles que nos habían enseñado en
aquella época y entendí rápidamente que
no era la prioridad la prioridad
[Música]
de ocho años conduce el camión de 14
toneladas como una bicicleta el padre
del niño Antoine acaba de retomar el
cultivo sus dudas sobre la posibilidad
de sostener a su familia con una granja
ecológica se disiparon el negocio de
rentable
[Música]
ahora sabemos que podemos hacer las
cosas de manera distinta de hecho es muy
fácil y funciona bien nos acercamos a 70
80 por ciento de los volúmenes
realizados con la agricultura
convencional de hecho a veces obtenemos
mejores resultados no hay problema
[Música]
La Apuesta es un éxito garantizar el
futuro
[Música]